in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
with me in the studio now is dr host
libert he's a gynecologist and hormone
specialist and the former head of the
department for gynecological
endocrinology at the charity hospital in
berlin professor welcome to the show how
dangerous is it to take the pill i mean
some contraceptives were removed from
the market in france not long ago
well there's one major concern
of women
due to the media also
that
women who have a increased genetic risk
for thrombosis
they should abstain from the pill
and there are other groups like women
who are heavily overweight
they have a major risk and
another important factor is increasing
age
is steeply also increasing the risk of
thromboembolism
and those groups should not take the
pill at all right every
woman that is prescribed a pill should
give a
very thorough personal history
to the doctor um or
he should ask about it before
prescribing an estrogen containing pill
so it's all about estrogen but there are
different hormones in the pill it's not
just estrogen right
the evil in the pill
concerning thromboembolism is the
estrogen
you could freely prescribe an
estrogen-free free contraceptive pill or
any kind of hormonal contraception that
does not contain an estrogen
and there you're pretty safe of not
increasing the risk so so that means if
i've got a patient who is smoking for
instance should i advise her to go on a
estrogen-free pill correct especially if
she is above 35 years of age or getting
older and you want to keep giving that
pill or she wants it then you should
indeed
recommend
to take a progestogen only contraceptive
is there anything else i can tell my
patients besides taking a special kind
of pill like drinking a lot of water and
taking a flight
um
well if you sweat a lot and your blood
is concentrating then
you're not drinking enough then you
increase your risk but also um remind
your patients about moving for example
if they go on a long trip
in a intercontinental flight that they
should get up and move their legs
can hormones really slow the aging
process
they can do some
good for the women
concerning major
mainly the bone
the skin
hair
and teeth
these are the organs that really
depend a lot on estrogens and so you
could if you want to say delay aging
for these organs so and what about
well-being so just feeling fitter
feeling when as far as
sometimes you know
sweating at night makes you disturb your
sleep
or if you have a hot flushes
during the day
that can disturb you very much and your
well-being is really deteriorating
sometimes if you have that and and do
people
feel older when they don't take hormones
yes sometimes i from my personal
experience i can see women when they
stop estrogens they come back and say
could i start again i was feeling much
better when i was taking them that
happens yes yeah this is true for women
who are on estrogen but they are also
men who are taking hormones our viewer
farhan jabba from australia is taking
hormones and for sports reason he just
wants some muscle mass to to build a
safe with bodybuilding from the
standpoint of an endocrinologist and
would you say this is okay to take some
hormones for muscle growth now we would
strongly
recommend against that
and this is kind of doping and
the risk that you're inducing is that
blood clots form more easily because the
red blood cells have
increased in number
and
that's why blood clots happen for
example in the coronary arteries and you
get a myocardial infarction so it's
really risky to take those hormones just
for sport reasons it is yes okay going
back to menopause menopausal women who
are undergoing hormonal replacement
therapy have sometimes be taking
hormones for years but there's evidence
that this replacement therapy itself may
be dangerous to the women's health
professor but what's the reason recent
research suggests with all those dangers
cancers
the main worry of women is does it
increase
breast cancer risk right and i think
there women are over worried
um if there is a woman with a normal
basal risk not an increased risk then
you could
tolerate a treatment if you have climate
symptoms for up to five years without
really increasing the risk that is the
present information that we get from all
those big studies so this means if you
take the period of hormones the women
take
charge then like five years you should
be on the safe side you are more or less
on the safe side under the condition
that the basic risks
of blood cancer breast cancer is okay
and you don't have an increased risk for
stroke or myocardial infarction
that's also very important and in my
office many women don't want to take
hormones at all because of this study
and we got a viewer question judith
santos from the u.s state of tennessee
she wants to know um are there any
advantages not to take hormones
well the
the funny thing is if you are
pretty healthy
and you are maybe between 50 and 60 and
you take hormones
then you protect your heart
healthy women have an advantage
unhealthy women
take a big risk
so so it's not even no not only safe to
take hormones over this five-year period
but it's better to take them than to
skip them concerning certain organs
concerning me mainly the heart we
believe and there is good evidence that
initiating hormone therapy
at an early
post-menopausal age does do good to your
heart and and what about all those
alternative medical things like
plant-based diets or like like plant
medicine things and not to take home
they cannot compete uh those
uh phyto hormones plant hormones they
cannot compete with those hormones that
are given in
hormonal
replacement therapy even in treating hot
flashes
even in that respect estrogens there's
nothing better than estrogens nothing
more effective
so if you've got a patient's with hot
flashes all those climatic problems and
symptoms what should they do just go and
see the gynecologist they should
get the advice from your his her
gynecologist and
really do a individual risk profile of
all these important diseases yeah
myocardial infarction breast cancer
stroke so it's all about the risk and
then ask your doctor now lost the risk
and then do it
thanks so much for being in the studio
thank you okay